Générique
...
Musique de tension
-La montagne :
sa verticalité, son altitude,
ses températures
parfois extrêmes,
la rendent aussi majestueuse
qu'imprévisible.
-La montagne est un milieu abrasif.
-C'est un monde dangereux.
-On subit la tyrannie du milieu.
-La montagne est
un espace répulsif qui,
aujourd'hui,
devient stratégique.
-Depuis que l'homme
se fait la guerre, ses dénivelés,
ses lignes de crête
et ses sommets enneigés
concentrent l'attention
des stratèges.
Point d'observation,
frontière naturelle,
ou encore zone refuge,
du résistant ou de l'insurgé,
cette géographie
particulière fait de la montagne
un milieu à part,
que l'homme en armes
se doit d'apprivoiser
ou du moins, de maîtriser.
-Dans le combat en montagne,
on a deux ennemis :
l'espace naturel
dans lequel on combat
et l'ennemi proprement dit.
-C'est aussi
une façon de raisonner le terrain,
de raisonner l'ennemi.
-A la fin des années 2000,
plus de la moitié des conflits
dans le monde
ont lieu en zone de montagne.
-En France, ils sont 8000 soldats
d'active et de réserve
à être spécialistes
du combat en montagne.
Rompus au relief et à l'évolution
en zone montagneuse,
ces militaires n'ont cessé
de mettre leur savoir-faire
au service des opérations.
Au sol, mais aussi dans les airs,
ils ont à chaque fois dû composer
avec ce milieu bien particulier,
pour partir à l'assaut,
dans la montagne.
Musique intense
...
-Les gars, de ce que j'ai vu
sur les dernières descentes,
dans l'ensemble,
c'est pas mal, d'accord ?
Là, grosso modo,
on va dire,
un jour et demi complet en station,
vous avez atteint le niveau
où vous êtes capables
de descendre
une piste bleue.
Pour des gars qui
n'avaient jamais ou presque jamais
skié avant, c'est déjà bien.
J'ai une section
de jeunes incorporés arrivés
en octobre 2022.
Là, ils ont fini la partie
qu'on appelle FGI,
formation générale initiale,
une formation qui dure
10 semaines et ensuite, là,
pendant cinq semaines,
on fait ce qu'on appelle
la formation montagne
hiver pour les chasseurs alpins.
Là, comme on...
est là vraiment au début,
pour apprendre à skier,
on commence en station.
Après,
dès la fin de semaine, on va faire
un peu de ski de randonnée
et dès la semaine prochaine,
partir
dans des domaines hors-piste
et découvrir ce que c'est,
le ski de randonnée militaire.
Musique douce
-Débuts difficiles
pour ces jeunes engagés.
Certains n'ont jamais skié.
A peine incorporés,
ils doivent apprendre à évoluer
dans ce milieu exigeant
qu'est la montagne, passage obligé
des chasseurs alpins.
...
-J'avais jamais skié,
mais ça s'apprend.
Si les autres y arrivent,
pourquoi pas moi.
Au début, c'est pas facile.
C'est compliqué.
On est là pour apprendre.
Ca sert à ça, le stage.
-Néanmoins, à deux semaines
d'apprentissage, les progrès sont
déjà visibles.
Si le ski de descente ne constitue
que la première étape, l'enjeu est
de gravir monts et sommets.
Comment ça se passe ?
-C'est très agréable. Je skiais déjà
dans ma vie civile avant.
Donc, c'est que du plaisir.
On touche le coeur
du chasseur alpin.
La montagne, c'est un milieu
très particulier, assez dur.
Donc, il faut être habitué
à la fois au froid et à la montée.
Et dans un second temps,
il y a de la bienveillance :
on doit être solidaires
les uns des autres,
pour aller au bout de la mission
en montagne.
-Ce stage de skieur militaire
de 5 semaines
a pour vocation d'enseigner
les techniques d'évolution
en saison hivernale
à cette jeune section.
-Les gars, tombez votre sac,
vous le mettez sur le côté.
Là, on est en plein...
C'est le stage brevet
skieur militaire,
un stage traditionnel
chez les chasseurs alpins.
Là, on fait deux semaines
de ski technique, donc c'est du ski
vraiment alpin en station.
Et ensuite, à partir...
Déjà, aujourd'hui,
et la semaine prochaine,
on va faire de la peau de phoque.
C'est ni plus ni moins
du ski de randonnée.
Et ça, c'est dans un but ultime :
c'est de finir
le stage par le brevet
skieur militaire. C'est...
1200 m de dénivelé,
à faire en moins de 4h30,
avec l'arme.
-Je suis en train d'installer
mes peaux de phoque,
car là, cet après-midi, on va faire
un peu de ski de randonnée.
Les peaux de phoque vont permettre
de monter la pente de la montagne
sans glisser...
-Et pour monter,
ces stagiaires vont se confronter
à différents ateliers :
montée en peau de phoque,
montée avec des crampons,
couteaux,
ski à dos : le but est de maîtriser
un panel de savoir-faire,
pour pallier toute situation
en montagne l'hiver.
-On se crée
sa petite plate-forme,
on s'équilibre avec les bâtons
ensuite. D'accord ?
Le ski intérieur,
on vient le placer, et pareil,
on le stabilise. D'accord ?
Et ensuite,
là, c'est pas trop raide,
la spatule du ski qui est en aval,
d'accord,
elle fait le tour du talon.
Comme ça.
D'accord ?
N'oubliez pas, quand vous chaussez,
vous passez bien en position haute.
Là, tu mets d'abord ta pointe.
Tu mets...
bien ta chaussure dans l'axe.
Allez, les gars.
On essaie d'être rapides !
C'est long, là.
OK.
Il y a encore
un peu de boulot.
Le stage est encore long.
Y a encore pas mal d'étapes.
Y a suffisamment
de temps d'entraînement
pour qu'ils soient prêts
le jour J.
C'est bon ?
Allez, ça déroule.
Le premier me suit,
et ainsi de suite.
Allez, go !
-Des sensations nouvelles.
C'est quelque chose
que je ne pratiquais pas.
Ca demande un petit peu
de... praticité :
connaître le matériel,
l'installer correctement,
et être rapide
dans les transitions.
On a différents matériels
suivant les montées.
Il faut savoir
changer rapidement de matériel.
Ca demande du temps
d'apprentissage
et de l'investissement.
-La route est longue
avant de devenir
un chasseur alpin chevronné.
En complément du brevet
de skieur militaire,
ces jeunes stagiaires apprendront
à se déplacer en montagne l'été.
Ce sera l'objet d'un autre stage,
celui d'alpiniste militaire.
Au programme :
escalade et ascension.
En hiver comme en été,
ils auront acquis les bases
de l'évolution en montagne.
-Le dénominateur commun,
c'est la capacité
à apprivoiser le milieu,
à maîtriser les conséquences
ou les contraintes du milieu.
Le brevet de skieur militaire,
d'alpiniste militaire,
ce sont des brevets que nous passons
en début de formation.
C'est la 1re marche des compétences
pour un soldat de montagne.
-Pour les pilotes d'hélicoptères
aussi,
la montagne est un milieu à part.
C'est ici, au coeur des Pyrénées,
dans un centre unique en France,
le Centre de vol en montagne,
que les jeunes pilotes,
aussi bien de l'armée de terre,
de l'armée de l'air, de l'espace,
de la marine nationale
que de la gendarmerie se forment.
Sur 10 mois de formation initiale,
ils passent 15 jours
à évoluer dans les reliefs.
Pour Edwin, le vol en montagne
est une découverte.
Depuis son arrivée au centre,
il y a une semaine,
il vole tous les jours.
Un objectif : savoir poser
son hélicoptère en montagne
en sécurité.
-Le vent a des effets spécifiques
en montagne.
En fonction du relief,
il va porter
plus ou moins la machine
ou la rabattre vers les reliefs.
Et donc, on aura le souci permanent
de la sécurité en déterminant
des zones de dégagement
pour éviter de percuter les reliefs.
-Donc, on va partir sur le 1er point
qu'on traitera certainement :
une ligne de crête.
D'accord ?
-Perché à 1300 m d'altitude,
et à proximité
de 11 zones d'entraînement,
le Centre de vol en montagne
est idéal
pour appréhender
ce milieu vertical.
Au total, 4000 mouvements
d'hélicoptères sont enregistrés ici
chaque année.
Au Centre de vol en montagne,
la formation est éprouvante.
Sous l'oeil attentif
du capitaine Laurent,
pilote depuis 24 ans,
Edwin entame son 7e vol en montagne
à bord de cet hélicoptère,
EC120 militarisé.
-En appliquant
une méthode spécifique
de raisonnement, d'approche
et de décollage,
il devra analyser
son environnement
pour identifier la meilleure zone.
-Au-delà de voler
sans les repères habituels,
comme l'horizon,
et de composer avec la météo
et l'aérologie spécifiques liées
à la montagne,
l'enjeu est d'appréhender
ce que les pilotes appellent
la limite de puissance.
En résumé, la capacité de portage
de l'appareil.
Et du fait de l'altitude
et de la densité de l'air,
les Pyrénées constituent
un terrain d'entraînement propice
pour cerner les limites
de l'appareil.
-Sa formation
au Centre de vol en montagne
accomplie, Edwin rejoindra
sa base-école de l'aviation légère
de l'armée de terre, à Dax,
pour terminer sa formation.
Par la suite, il se spécialisera
et sera amené à piloter
sur hélicoptères de manoeuvre
ou d'attaque
en opérations extérieures.
Opérations sur des terrains
rarement privés de relief
et d'altitude.
-La troisième dimension
pour relancer
la manoeuvre en montagne,
c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui est essentiel.
On peut s'en passer,
mais c'est une plus-value énorme.
Nous l'avons utilisée,
nous l'utilisons.
Nous sommes en relation constante
avec nos camarades de l'ALAT,
avec lesquels on a combattu,
en particulier, au Sahel.
Et donc, cette capacité
à appréhender l'aérologie,
la complexité de ce milieu-là,
en fait, ça nous donne des...
Un vocabulaire et une grammaire
que nous partageons
avec nos camarades de l'ALAT.
-Savoir skier
ou encore voler en montagne
ne suffisent pas
pour combattre dans ce milieu.
C'est à Chamonix,
dans le temple
de l'alpinisme français,
à l'Ecole militaire
de haute montagne,
que les cadres
des soldats de montagne viennent
se former, encore et toujours.
Et c'est même un passage obligé.
Ils sont 650 stagiaires
à venir éprouver ici la montagne
chaque année,
en été comme en hiver.
-Du coup, aujourd'hui,
petite phase de synthèse
sur 3 jours. 3 jours de déplacement,
2 nuits de stationnement.
Tout ça pour vous faire acquérir
les actes réflexes
du grand froid,
des techniques grand froid.
Ca va nous permettre d'utiliser,
comme si vous étiez en opérationnel,
les pulkas,
les tentes grand froid,
et les réchauds grand froid.
Donc, un petit déplacement, là,
de 400 m,
jusqu'au point de stationnement.
Et demain,
une course en montagne
jusqu'à la tête de Bostan.
-L'objectif à atteindre,
dans des conditions éprouvantes,
est un sommet,
perché à 2300 m d'altitude.
Pour mener à bien cette mission,
ils tractent des pulkas,
ces traîneaux,
pesant près de 70 kg,
contenant vivres
et tentes pour la nuit.
-Les derniers, hésitez pas
à prendre large dans le virage.
-Pour le capitaine Benoît,
c'est une première.
-Ca se passe bien.
On avance à une bonne vitesse.
Le poids de la pulka est soutenable.
-Avant de devenir commandant d'unité
au sein de son régiment,
il doit effectuer ce stage,
de six semaines,
pour devenir chef de détachement
en haute montagne,
c'est-à-dire être formé
à emmener une section en altitude.
-La formation de chef de détachement
haute montagne
hiver, pour la saison actuelle,
nous permet d'emmener
avec un très grand degré d'autonomie
une troupe
de chasseurs alpins
avec de la formation.
Ca nous permet deux choses :
soit de les former initialement,
soit de les emmener
lors de différentes sorties,
soit purement techniques,
soit des sorties tactiques,
et mettre en oeuvre des techniques
apprises dans du grand froid
à différentes saisons.
-Mais avant d'atteindre
la tête de Bostan,
le groupe fait halte pour la nuit.
-Là, on est arrivés
dans la zone de stationnement.
On attend le détachement,
qui arrive avec les pulkas.
Ils sont juste là,
derrière nous.
Le but est de trouver la zone
la plus plate possible
de manière à monter une tente Mess
pour manger le soir
et des tentes individuelles
pour que les trinômes y dorment.
-Bon, les gars...
-Eux, ils se mettent là.
Et nous, là-bas.
-Là, la priorité,
avec des temps
comme aujourd'hui,
c'est le souci de l'humain.
- aujourd'hui, il neige,
il fait pas froid -
de manière à ce qu'on s'abrite
et qu'on soit
le moins mouillés possible.
Dans un premier temps,
c'est de l'humain et ensuite,
on monte les tentes.
C'est le matériel après.
Là, on a quand même
le grand confort.
Vous avez vu, en pulkas,
c'est 200 m/h maximum.
OK ? Donc le chef,
il faut bien
qu'il pense à faire tourner
les tireurs,
les tracteurs tireurs de pulkas,
et surtout, là...
-60 cm de neige est tombée
pendant la nuit,
et les vents avoisinent les 70 km/h.
Le jour d'exercice
n'est pas un choix au hasard
des instructeurs,
au contraire.
Pas question pour les stagiaires
de renoncer pour autant.
-Alors,
pourquoi c'est nécessaire ?
Parce que la montagne est difficile.
Il faut avoir de l'expérience
et connaître toutes les techniques,
de manière à pouvoir
les appliquer au combat,
car les conflits de demain
seront peut-être
dans des zones montagneuses
ou enneigées
ou des zones grand froid polaire.
Ca peut arriver.
Donc nous, c'est des techniques
et des savoir-faire qu'on apprend
à nos stagiaires de manière à avoir
cette veille opérationnelle
pour que les stagiaires puissent,
je ne l'espère pas,
un jour, peut-être,
s'en servir
en zone grand froid,
en zone polaire ou zone montagne,
d'un point de vue tactique
et combat.
-La montagne,
c'est de l'opérationnel.
On l'a vu cette semaine,
puisqu'en fait,
on est constamment
confrontés au danger.
Le danger en montagne,
ce sera,
en montagne technique,
ce ne sera pas l'ennemi,
mais le milieu,
qui est extrêmement difficile,
et un mauvais choix peut conduire
assez rapidement
à une situation hasardeuse,
voire catastrophique.
C'est une situation
très opérationnelle
qui nous aide à prendre
des décisions très importantes,
dans un cadre engagé
et engageant,
et qui vont avoir un impact immédiat
sur le succès de la mission.
-Un soldat qui n'est pas entraîné
à ce milieu particulier,
face à l'agression climatique,
face au défi physique,
face à la verticalité,
peut avoir tendance
à se concentrer
sur sa propre survie
et négliger
les impératifs du combat.
C'est pour ça
que nous nous entraînons,
pour dépasser ce stade.
Ca nous met en bonne position
pour intervenir
sur les théâtres froids,
par exemple le nord de l'Europe,
ou pourquoi pas l'Arctique,
si, un jour, il y avait un besoin
d'intervenir dans cette zone.
-Ces savoir-faire montagneux sont
le fruit d'une longue tradition
militaire.
-Mettre plus de poids...
-Du fait de sa géographie,
entre les Alpes,
les Pyrénées,
les Vosges et le Jura,
la France est un pays
où la montagne fait figure
de frontière naturelle.
-C'est surtout
à partir de la constitution
de l'Etat moderne
qu'il y a besoin
de protéger les frontières,
en particulier
ces frontières naturelles,
fondées sur l'élément montagne,
et c'est pour éviter,
justement, que des armées
adverses puissent traverser,
que les militaires,
les armées,
de manière générale,
ont cherché à protéger
les grands axes d'accès.
Il faut attendre
la fin du 19e siècle,
plus exactement,
le décret de 1888,
pour voir les premières unités.
Des bataillons de chasseurs à pied
sont mis en place
pour protéger les périphéries
frontalières en zone de montagne.
-Néanmoins,
il faudra attendre plus de 50 ans
pour que les 1res instructions
spécialisées au combat en montagne
voient le jour.
-Le premier texte vraiment officiel
est un manuel d'alpinisme,
destiné aux militaires.
Un an après, il y aura
la première instruction provisoire
pour les opérations
des grandes unités en montagne.
On est en 1932.
C'est relativement récent,
mais en même temps très tôt,
si on compare la montagne
par rapport à d'autres espaces,
comme la ville ou la jungle.
-Et c'est une première
en rapport avec
un espace spécifique.
Les instructions au combat en milieu
désertique, forestier et urbain
n'apparaîtront, elles,
qu'après la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
-Pour la première fois,
on voit un milieu être pris à part
par rapport à ce que l'on pense
de l'art de la guerre.
La montagne suscite
un certain intérêt.
Tout au long du 19e siècle,
il faut attendre
l'après-Première Guerre mondiale
pour voir la pensée militaire
évoluer
et le métier militaire évoluer,
par rapport à ce type de milieu.
-Depuis, le combat en montagne
n'a cessé d'évoluer,
au fil des opérations : de la
résistance du plateau des Glières
en 1944,
au massif des Ifoghas, au Mali.
-La Bosnie-Herzégovine,
dans les années 90,
le Kosovo, en 1999,
l'Afghanistan, que vous avez cité,
le Mali,
l'Afrique sahélienne,
de manière générale,
dans les années 2000,
jusqu'aux années 2020,
lorsque l'on regarde
une carte des conflits,
fin des années 2000,
on voit que plus de la moitié
des conflits dans le monde
ont lieu en zone de montagne.
-Et dans ces confrontations,
une constante apparaît :
la montagne
est l'espace de la guérilla
par excellence.
-La montagne a toujours été
une zone refuge, un terrain
qui est propice à l'insurgé,
parce que c'est un terrain
où une force classique ne peut pas
utiliser complètement ses armes,
en tout cas, l'effet de ses armes
est beaucoup moins efficace
qu'en zone de plaine.
-Une opération extérieure
a profondément
marqué le retour
du combat en montagne :
notre engagement en Afghanistan,
entre 2001 et 2014.
Alors chef de corps
du 27e bataillon
de chasseurs alpins,
le général Le Nen
est déployé avec ses hommes,
fin 2008, en Kapissa,
la zone d'opération française
en Afghanistan.
-Alors,
notre état d'esprit en Kapissa,
d'abord, c'était...
C'était un peu un aboutissement,
pour nous tous.
C'est-à-dire que...
on allait renouer
avec une opération extérieure
qui allait se dérouler
dans notre milieu de prédilection,
puisque la Kapissa,
c'est une province montagneuse,
qui est constituée de vallées
et qui étaient encadrées
par des sommets de 3000 m,
donc c'était notre terrain.
Notre état d'esprit,
c'était l'aboutissement,
une forme de retour aux sources,
et donc,
on s'est entraînés pour ça.
-Dans cet environnement accidenté,
fait de sommets et de gorges,
tous les principes du combat
en montagne ont été mobilisés.
-On était vigilants, d'abord,
à tenir les positions hautes,
parce que celui qui ne tient pas
les positions hautes en montagne,
que ce soit au 20e siècle
ou au 17e siècle,
se met d'emblée en position
d'infériorité,
donc on tenait systématiquement
les parties hautes du terrain
avant de s'engager dans les vallées.
On s'assurait
des lignes de communication
pour conserver
notre liberté d'action.
-Son mandat afghan sera notamment
marqué par la bataille d'Alasaï,
opposant les soldats de la coalition
aux talibans de Gulbuddin Hekmatyar.
-La domination du champ de bataille,
l'ubiquité,
la complémentarité des feux,
la préparation aux conditions
de l'engagement. La combinaison
de ces principes tactiques,
spécifiques au combat en montagne,
ont permis le succès de l'opération.
-Les opérations militaires
en Afghanistan marquent un retour
du combat en montagne
et assoient des tactiques éprouvées
et démontrent la nécessité
de maintenir un savoir-faire.
-Moi,
quand je suis rentré
dans l'armée de terre,
la guerre en montagne était
un concept assez éloigné.
Jamais je n'aurais pensé
qu'un jour,
j'aurais à faire la guerre
dans un pays comme l'Afghanistan,
à conduire des opérations de combat
en montagne.
Pourtant, on l'a fait.
L'enseignement : il ne faut jamais
injurier l'avenir.
-La montagne a tendance à niveler
la supériorité technologique,
parce que face
à l'observation aérienne,
face à l'usage
des bombes,
il est relativement facile,
pour un homme à pied, d'échapper
à la surveillance, et donc,
si on choisit d'investir
cette zone montagneuse,
il faut y engager des unités
qui y soient préparées, capables
d'accepter de descendre
dans l'arène
pour aller se confronter
à cette opposition...
j'allais dire... directe,
et les yeux dans les yeux.
Pétarade de tirs
...
-En avant, les gars !
Maintenez le contact !
Gardez la ligne !
...
-En pleine nuit, la compagnie de
chasseurs alpins est prise à partie.
L'exercice n'a pas commencé
que les procédures sont éprouvées.
-Je suis au contact. Au contact.
-Contact à gauche !
-Contrôle radio.
-Les gars sont sur le nord-ouest.
3 Pax.
Tirs au loin
OK, j'ai mon homme
qui a été pris à partie,
au niveau du village
de Saint-Antoine.
3 Pax,
côté nord-est du village.
-Aux alentours de Modane,
dans les Alpes,
cet exercice de combat en montagne
démarre tambour battant.
Il faut réagir vite pour reprendre
le dessus sur l'adversaire.
C'est au terme de 2 heures
de manoeuvres dans la nuit noire
que la situation se stabilise.
-La zone du hameau est sécurisée.
On a fouillé...
Les mecs ont dû rompre le contact
vers le nord, la direction ennemie.
Et du coup,
on va se désengager du hameau,
on va retourner sur notre bivouac
et se remettre en défense.
-Sur le qui-vive, ces hommes
du 13e bataillon de chasseurs alpins
rejoignent leur tente pour profiter
du peu de sommeil qu'il leur reste,
car 2 heures plus tard,
la vraie mission débute.
-30, départ. Premier objectif :
hameau, Saint-Antoine.
-Objectif à atteindre,
un fort, perché dans la montagne.
Pour y parvenir, il faut être
le plus furtif possible :
la zone est truffée d'ennemis.
(-Comme ça, tu prends un mec,
tu vas jusque là-bas.)
-On se met en place
sur l'itinéraire d'infiltration.
Les deux autres groupes
de la section
vont se mettre en place
pour l'appui.
-C'est quoi, la contrainte,
de naviguer et de manoeuvrer
dans le relief ?
-La première contrainte
est physique.
Forcément, les...
Les efforts sont plus soutenus.
La 2e contrainte, c'est que...
L'ennemi est sur le haut
et on est sur le bas.
Ca nécessite pas mal
de coordination, des débordements,
enfin, des gros détours
pour essayer, en fait,
de récupérer des positions
sur les hauteurs
pour gagner sur l'ennemi.
-Dans le combat en montagne,
tout est une affaire
de coordination.
Echanges de tirs
...
Alors que les premiers efforts
ont été fournis par une section,
une autre prend le relais
pour gagner du terrain
dans cet environnement éprouvant.
-Vincent,
tu maintiens l'appui en face !
-Les contraintes,
elles sont multiples. La première,
c'est le temps
que prend chaque déplacement,
puisque c'est fatigant,
plus long.
On a des contraintes
au niveau des liaisons
radio également, puisqu'avec
les changements d'altitude,
il n'y a pas forcément tout
qui passe.
On est aussi contraints
par l'apport en munitions :
en dénivelé positif, on ne peut pas
apporter énormément de choses.
Donc il y a pas mal de contraintes,
qui s'ajoutent à ça. Il y a un vrai
travail de logistique qui est fait
au niveau de la compagnie
pour qu'on soit appuyés
par la section de commandement
au fur et à mesure de l'opération.
-On est dans un terrain qui,
souvent, reste relativement vierge.
Tout ça pour dire que...
les options, les routes à prendre,
ne sont pas multiples. En fait,
le terrain, non seulement
il s'impose aux combattants,
mais en plus,
il n'a pas été préparé
ou remodelé par la main de l'homme,
en tant que tel,
et donc, les contraintes sont
encore plus fortes.
Contrairement à ce qu'on peut
penser, le combat en montagne
se fait aussi
au milieu des populations qui,
le jour où elles choisissent
de prendre les armes,
sont les mieux placées
pour y combattre efficacement.
-OK, Matthieu,
tu resteras bien sur la droite.
Tu restes bien dans la pente.
Nous, on va se retirer vers toi,
se resserrer un peu sur la droite.
-Visuel, Antoine !
Echanges de tirs
...
-Voilà !
Salve de tirs
-Allez, écrase-moi ça !
-300 m de dénivelé positif
plus tard,
le fort du Sapey.
Il aura fallu 6 heures
pour l'atteindre.
-A 50 m en direction de mon bras,
entre les poteaux électriques.
-Un blessé !
Un blessé ! Un blessé !
-OK, tu restes là.
Lâche ta bécane, viens...
-Au terme de 3 heures d'assaut,
ces hommes obtiennent enfin
l'avantage
sur l'adversaire, retranché
dans ces habitations.
-Avance encore !
Avance.
Relève-toi un peu.
-Assaut terminé. 5,5 neutralisé
dans les baraquements.
-Si le combat en montagne
a nécessairement évolué
au fil des opérations, la tyrannie
de ce milieu reste intangible.
Maîtriser la montagne
ne s'improvise pas.
Et au terme de plus
d'un siècle d'existence,
les troupes de montagne n'ont cessé
de cultiver leur esprit de cordée
et savoir-faire particulier
pour une finalité :
faire de ce milieu un atout,
pour conserver la supériorité
au combat.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...